well russell wilson continues to be in
the headlines two weeks after that
interview with dan patrick that that i
think turned the seahawks on their head
and made the rest of the nfl take notice
that things have really changed when it
comes to quarterbacks russell wilson
making it clear he's not happy there
hasn't been a lot of development since
then the seahawks reportedly weren't
thrilled with russell wilson doing what
he did and saying what he said mike
silver of nfl media reported yesterday a
couple of things as it relates to
russell wilson first
at least a third of the league has
called the seahawks why as shereen
williams said last night on pftpm why
hasn't more of the league called it's
russell wilson for crying out loud and
secondly
the thinking around the league is that
the starting point for russell wilson is
three first-round draft picks which
doesn't seem unreasonable the question
is whatever the ending point is will
that be enough to get the seahawks to
say
we'll take the deal and we'll move on no
i i mean
they they
it seems like they're sick of each other
that's what i really want to just say i
mean that's where it seems that's what
it looks like you know again russell
yeah i think that was
a little bit of a pre-planned propaganda
effort
uh with the dan patrick interview
certainly i do think it was a little bit
of a
a low blow to the seahawks to talk about
the sax thing i do you know listen
russell wilson's awesome we both are
huge fans
man he takes a lot of sacks because of
russell wilson it's not always because
of the offensive line out of all the
great quarterbacks i would tell you that
russell wilson turns down more people
that are open in the middle of the field
than any of them now he makes it work
somehow some way and he's clutch as hell
in the fourth quarter and all that but
how can the seattle seahawks not be a
little annoyed with russell wilson the
way he you know acted right after the
super bowl well and it's not just the
seahawks you got teammates who
are responsible for blocking for russell
wilson they see that walter jones hall
of fame left tackle for seattle seahawks
has been outspoken in his belief that
russell was out of line calling out his
teammates i mean
it was stunning because it was delivered
in a very calm and rational way
we didn't quite appreciate in the moment
the impact of what he was saying he was
doing something that quarterbacks
typically don't do which is blame anyone
for anything related in any way to their
failures or struggles on the football
field but it it does seem to be part of
a broader effort to get a fresh start
and to agitate to get the seahawks
sufficiently upset so they're ready to
move on as well right i think that's
what you need it can't just be russell
wants out the seahawks have to see that
this guy's making it a pain in the butt
so yeah let's go ahead and take the best
offer that someone gives us well i would
think like you know it would take at
least three first rounds or three first
rounders right that would that would
make sense certainly but russell wilson
it seems like he wants to go somewhere
and you know make it all about him in a
way not that all about him but he wants
to play in a a free-flowing offense
where he gets to put on a show like
patrick mahomes and josh allen and you
know aaron rodgers and his prime and do
that and i think he feels you know
handicapped that way to a degree
handcuffed a little bit
uh but in the same way
there's a contract here that makes it
you know you know they just paid him i
paid him a lot of money that makes
things tough there too
and
as much as i think
i in my gut i really feel like the
seahawks would like to get get rid of
get like get the hell out of here
russell wilson we don't want to deal
with you and we'll find somebody else i
would think they want to do that but i
don't think their team right now is
capable of you know overcoming that it'd
be one thing if we were five years ago
and it was that defense was still there
and they can run the ball and then you'd
go okay they can still find a way to win
a lot of games with another quarterback
but right now
that defense is a huge question mark and
they're not in the place that i think
you can just say we're going to win
games without russell wilson they kind
of need him and i think that's what
makes the conversation very interesting
too
the team that makes the most sense for
conversation purposes and maybe for
ultimate transaction purposes is the new
york jets because they have the second
overall pick right they've got the two
first-round picks that the jets got in
the jamal adams trade so the jets have
four over the next two years and they've
got sam darn exactly i don't think it's
gonna take four first-round picks and
sam darnold no way to get russell wilson
but look
from the jets standpoint russell wilson
instantly gives them something they
haven't had in 50 years in a franchise
quarterback a true short list franchise
quarterback who fills a stadium assuming
that the stadium is allowed to be filled
this year and in new jersey they're
they're moving in that direction
although they got a long way to go i i
just i think the jets would make a ton
of sense they've got the draft capital
the question is do they want to do it
and robert sala knows russell wilson as
well as anyone because he's had to
prepare to defend against him multiple
times per year for the past several
years no doubt no doubt you know again
like deshawn watson the conversation
with that yesterday i mean the dolphins
the panthers i would think that would be
part of the conversation too why
wouldn't it be i mean he could go to
those places and be successful also
if you're the houston texans aren't you
know
wouldn't you call and go away we could
just swap quarterbacks here we don't
really gotta there's very little
particulars here that we'd have to
figure out would russell wilson be
willing to go down to houston and do
that i don't know but that just when i
first heard a lot of this conversation
that's what popped up to my head so i
would think there's opportunities we'll
see where it goes
that's a great idea too remember what
richard sherman said to deshaun watson
after the rookie year game in seattle
sherman said to watson you played us
tougher than any quarterback ever
has that was in seattle the only time
that those two teams had squared off
well maybe they did in 2020 they did in
2020 right it was seattle at houston i
got to go back and look at 17 18 19 20.
yeah i think that's right every four
years i don't know i can't remember
right now either i've gotten myself
twisted up and confused
uh about a lot of things right now let
me just say this before we go 39 million
dollar cap charge they would have to
take by trading him if you defer the
trade until after june 1 it can be 13
million this year and 26 million next
year which makes it a little bit easier
and one last point before we take a
break
no one really quite knows who's calling
the shots in seattle ever since paul
allen passed his sister jody allen runs
the team there are some who think that
basically it's just an extension of the
broader vulcan industrial group right
and there really isn't one person who
has that clear power to say yes or no
that could be a complicated thing i
think it's his last year in seattle
regardless that's what obviously and if
that's the point if that's the point why
not just do it now yeah why not just do
it just do it now not let's not have one
last year do it now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports